[Music]
people call me from around the world and
literally say are you the crazy guy
that's growing coffee in California
welcome to the rolling hills of Goleta
California and the Dominion of a man
named Jay rusty I'm Jay [ __ ] I'm the
first person to grow coffee in the
contents of the United States this farm
is the first farm that's commercially if
growing coffee in California so where
you're standing here is where it all
started
I'm Jesse Anselmi and I'm a member of
Panera's innovation team it's my job to
seek out the latest innovations in
coffee in the food and beverage space
once we heard Jays story we knew it was
a story that needed to be told and like
Panera it's really a story about
innovation Coffee is not typically grown
in the content on us it's generally
grown in tropical regions because of
soil chemistry and environmental
profiles so we basically have been in
our writing that looked on how to grow
it
luckily I'm kind of naive and tenacious
so I just kind of keep pushing on and I
for the last 28 years have been pursuing
niche crops exotic fruit crops in
California and now it's been coffee so
we're a really great spot here because
this is an interaction between the Hass
avocado and two coffees since they have
similar needs to coffee plants avocados
served as a sort of litmus test plus
they provided the sort of dappled shade
that coffee trees love soon it became
clear that growing coffee in California
was more than a crazy idea but
innovation doesn't stop in the field
post harvest is incredibly involved in
ever improving across
and it takes a dedicated team to get it
done it's quite a challenge of saying I
want to start a brand new industry in
terms of innovation I am a big fan that
what I call a diversity of thought so a
lot of the fringe team comes from other
industries and that type of diversity I
think helps accelerate what we're doing
and together they really help each other
to grow so what makes a good cup of
coffee you know we're in the pursuit of
the perfect cup Panera doesn't purchase
coffee from Jay today but the care that
Jay and his team put into fringe coffee
really reflects the care that Panera
puts into our coffees Coffee is a very
hands-on process every coffee cherry is
hand-picked for Panera coffee it is
checked by hand inspected by hand at the
point of origin and it really follows a
strict process to ensure that the best
quality cup of coffee is getting into
the hands of our consumers I'll drink to
that
you